hello and welcome to this video playing
ESO call here mr. sir colin let's forget
the bank already I'm on fifty percent
against him after being very very very
far behind so if I get a win in here
with this I would I could be actually I
would be ahead cool stuff so maybe I
manage that what is this really I'm not
getting a good porn sent agendas in this
position I'd seem
and also of course happy not getting a
visual pal but you can go Knight f3
maybe I mean it has he has to go in
either three what else is there Bishop d
593 ok this movers them interesting it's
interesting to take with the pawn now
because he cannot play you three okay
I'm trying that he has this Bishop kind
of out in the open at this night out out
in the open here
yes I'm not a porn down it looks like a
position where you would have
compensation for a portlet i'm not i'm
not a pawn down so what is he playing
now my threat is d for years to teach
acclaim and ask him about all this
development yeah i should have gotten
just 9 a-3 that was for still okay for
wine I mean here this might might also
be okay but I don't quite see how it
looks a bit weird to me
okay so too easy here is going back so
I'll play d4 it basically has to play
III now the question is do I have more
than just taking and being fine probably
not okay takes with the pawn can scrap
center space
hmm ok if he gets he probably is out for
long castles here I go D for he will
probably cancel long
ok now that cat rd5 if I shouldn't have
plenty five it seems that was to earlier
that porn is this week now ok I see
however I know I don't have ok
and no check for King etool jack what a
funny position don't get stuff like that
too often so what you do here the show
on age three my night is really really
awful hmm I don't know
we don't don't quite see how I get to
his his his King here
okay let's play this and then think
about it a little bit more this one I ok
quindi three rookie 3 is interesting and
f1 Gary of f1's extremely risky but
maybe it's okay Queen f6 there is 95 mm
may I plays it capture on c5 is the
issue you're ready open okay my night
isn't playing we're painting on the aid
for example Queen g2 Bishop g2 is the
same problem em mai roo Kang's Bishop
takes Queen of two probably okay so i
need i need to give up the rock down
there is no other way time morning
that's a bit of a shame that was really
an excellent position in the opening but
I did not did not play a ride check
page six is hanging yeah okay it's
really it's really annoying to lose this
game side but okay it happened I mean
this is pretty pretty bad for white but
I played t5 too early I just played it
too early probably too early now
something like a six or so but d6 i
don't know- if I cannot go d5 it's not
as brilliant as it as I thought it would
be and now it's a problem and you five
is this hanging Jim and I mean this this
looks pretty awful but it's a it's also
a question what my pieces are doing you
jack I have this this is stuck here and
this is a big issue really where this is
seems to lose after FY mmm Queen f6 is
still kind of okay but I mean this is a
very very difficult position to play
yeah I wonder maybe maybe I could have
could have played the opening opening
better this looked excellent because of
the d4 idea but it wasn't all that great
i mean because black should have
something substantial here what'swhat's
opening player is just wrong there
should be seven s what the engine gives
her hmm now going back and take with
this now
yeah there is a point I mean I actually
automatically in this kind of situation
assumed i would go back right even this
is great and this is excellent so we
should be seven just be should be seven
I was extremely happy with this but one
thing that I underestimated really is
also that you can take with the pawn i
was jacking thinking about this more and
this is this is really good but this is
better because of this pressure here and
interesting opening play early so i
should play Bishop e7 you know what this
is not great because he gives me the
bishop pair for no particular
compensation and I'm getting the pawn
back very easily with various central
control so I really should have an
advantage and this is the way to get it
with Bishop e7 I was expecting this but
this is also also fairly nice and you
get to get d5 and hmm ok I was a good
result for the opening but bad result at
the at the end of the game ok guys
thanks for watching